I think in fourth grade you learned
about the Civil War which is very
important but you also learn who your
enemies are
do you learn a lot in the fourth grade
the interview what's the difference
between arteries and veins arteries ok
Baines all right are these things a vein
is like well I know what a vein is but
it's like a let it's a less important
it's like a it's like a so that the
stump of the tree is the artery and then
the branches are the veins so the artery
is the important part paint before your
blood runs and then arteries are it's it
inside the vein see which piece okay I
think I got it
okay I got it an artery brings blood to
the heart and veins take it away who
came up with the three laws of motion
that would be three laws of motion
[ __ ] I'd say what start doing him did
they work together like Einstein and
dark you should go okay I feel good
about life now when was the American
Revolutionary War I remember it like it
was yesterday
1842 1812 is that against England vvu
1930 earlier than 1930 is 1838 and
repeat 1778
1785 to 1801 1776 to 1783 keep dance all
day we could dance all day
really I'd say that's [ __ ] really
1775 solve 120 3/5 I don't remember how
to do one of your vision at all
five goes into twelve family food so you
can go five times too and it's ten five
goes into 120 times or twenty four yet
20 times this doesn't mean anything that
was just for my brain and you got this
pesky little three here I don't know
what we do with this part but we're 24.3
baby and then five doesn't go into three
so I have no idea I'm just gonna do that
play 4.2 I made it up and your answer is
twenty four point six look at that you
don't even need to know long division
it's all [ __ ] you just multiply
everything